this chart looks at investment grade
corporate debt or debt that ratings
firms consider pretty safe there's a lot
of it out there right now over the past
decade
companies borrowed more and more as
interest rates hovered near zero
now analysts are concerned that's
because about half of that debt or 3.7
trillion dollars is rated triple B the
lowest rating investment grade dad can
receive and some are worried this debt
isn't as safe as the ratings suggest
companies that make well known products
like Campbell's chicken soup and Elmer's
glue have had debt rated triple B
analysts say the debt could be a mess in
the making especially if the economy
enters a recession to understand why
investors are concerned you need to
understand how corporate debt is rated
think of these ratings as credit scores
for corporations but instead of using
numbers ratings firms assign letter
grades from A to D the higher the grade
the less likely the company is to
default on its debt each one of those
ratings is broken down further into
triple double and single letter
categories so triple-a debt is safer
than single a triple B debts it's just
above an important dividing line
everything above this line is considered
higher quality investment grade debt
everything below is considered risky or
junk debt it carries a higher risk of
default the worry is that if the economy
takes the turn some triple B debt will
slide into junk territory a key metric
for how these ratings are assigned is
leverage leverage is a ratio of how much
debt a company owes compared to its
earnings the more debt a company has
relative to its earnings the higher the
leverage it's an important factor in
determining how safe a company's debt
might be since the financial crisis
companies have a lot more leverage in
2009 corporations had a little over
twice as much debt than earnings by 2019
that ratio had increased to about three
earnings and when you just look at
triple b-rated debt that ratio is even
higher this is what's concerning
investors and analysts they say that in
the past companies with this amount of
leverage would have been rated in the
junk category which is far riskier this
has caused a divisive debate over
whether this debt will cause big losses
when the economy turns business debt has
clearly reached a level that should give
businesses and investors reason to pause
and reflect
if financial economic conditions were to
deteriorate overly indebted firms could
well face severe strains for their part
ratings firms like Moody's and S&P say
other factors also play a role in
assigning ratings having a solid brand
and generating sufficient cash flow to
pay bondholders can also influence a
company being rated investment grade
ratings firms make predictions about
what a company's leverage ratio will
look like in the future for highly
leveraged companies these predictions
can serve as a deadline to keep their
investment grade status if a company
doesn't hit its target it runs the risk
of being downgraded but the amount of
times some triple B companies have been
given to meet these deadlines has left
some investors scratching their heads in
2018
Moody's said the triple B rating for
Campbell Soup was too high after it
acquired a snack company for six point 1
billion dollars it estimated the
company's leverage had topped five times
earnings
Moody's gave the company until July 2020
to get it below four times earnings
ratings firms predicted Newell brands
which makes Elmer's glue would reduce
its debt load for multiple years when
triple B evaded Newell announced a
multi-billion dollar acquisition in
December 2015 S&P and Moody's analysts
predicted its leverage ratio would fall
for more than five times to under four
times earnings by December 2017 they
continued to make similar predictions
that Newell would be a safe bet in 2016
2017 and 2018 but these 2018
calculations failed to account for lost
earnings from businesses Newell had sold
at the time moody
said its calculation was just a
different way of measuring leverage an
S&P spokesman told the Wall Street
Journal that our analysis speaks for
itself
updated calculations from both firms
showed Knowles debt was above five times
earnings at the end of 2018 revealing
that the bonds had been a potentially
riskier investment than what the ratings
firms indicated S&P downgraded Newell's
debt to junk status in November
Moody's still rates it triple B but
investors still remain skeptical more
than 100 billion dollars in investment
grade debt is trading with yields that
are usually associated with junk debt
these bonds are rated triple B - the
absolute lowest rung of investment grade
debt the Federal Reserve raised the
alarm about the volume of outstanding
triple B debt in November saying that
widespread downgrades during an economic
slowdown could disrupt the liquidity of
the corporate bond market potentially
leaving investors in a sticky situation